darsan allah battlefield ones weaponry
is super exciting to me we have been
allowed to open up a totally new world
it's not another m16 that we're about to
build just a huge 4i their weapons in
this war I mean everything from clubs
and very medieval brutal clothes water
weapons too fast firing machine guns and
submachine guns these weapons for the
time were the peak of engineering we've
done extensive research in order to
recreate these weapons both in how they
sound what they feel like how you handle
them in order to recreate them to
perfection this several of us realized
I've been dreaming about making these
games in the setting for over a decade
so in the background there's been
research going on for a long time i
would say world war one was the birth of
a lot of the things that we take for
granted in in modern warfare all of
these tools were created for a special
purpose right there right now they
needed to solve a problem and they came
up with this variety of tools we're not
recreating the old the past we're taking
death as an inspiration and then we're
trying to take this into a modern
perspective it is a different experience
it's much more up close and personal
every weapon has its unique character
and personality and it really brings it
to the battlefield it's more amazing
than I ever thought it would be it's
really about being overlooked for very
much myself to to play
play it first on Xbox one with EA access